it is supposed to be One Step Beyond The
Red Pill to see that life and dating
largely for men there's an uncomfortable
reality that if you aren't blessed with
the right physical attractiveness status
or money if you don't have the right
prerequisite you're basically doomed
you're a genetic dead end each if we're
looking at a species let's look at deer
what is natural is that one Buck
inseminates 50 doe and he competes with
all the other deer and the reason for
that is because then it actually allows
the quote Best genes to proliferate now
best is determined by what actually
continues on the point that I wanted to
make was not I think where everyone
thinks I'm going with this which is that
a lot of the black pill I would imagine
are casting an expectation on the
universe that it shouldn't be this way
why not and this is exactly like the
hater who says you're not going to
amount to anything and the reason it
hurts is because you're like what if
they're right because the thing is is
that like in order to be the top one
percent or even the top ten percent or
even just above average right you just
need to not be overweight you need to be
gainfully employed the bar is so
unbelievably low